salut bienvenue sur l'émission minute
forme donc aujourd'hui on est avec
Elodie ça
vaod donc on va voir avec les altes donc
le dos bien plat le genou bien dans
l'axe ok donc voilà donc dans ce
mouvement on cuisses les fessiers et
bien sûr on va cibler l'arrière des bras
ok donc là mouvement des altères de haut
en bas on colle coude près du corps et
on va contracter le bras dans
l'extension voilà on inspire on ouvre la
poitrine les épaules bien vers l'arrière
voilà donc ce mouvement vous pouvez le
faire entre 20 et 30 répétitions pour
bien tonifier et affiner le bras ok donc
vous pouvez alterner gauche et droite
donc sur TR à 5 séries
de de 10 à 30 répétitions donc plus
Elodie va descendre sur les jambes plus
elle va travailler les cuisses et les
fessiers donc bien travailler sur sa
silhouette donc ce mouvement vous pouvez
le faire face à un miroir pour vous
corriger par vous-même ou vous faire
aider par un
coach merci à vous merci de votre
attention on se dit à très bientôt et
merci encore extension triceps faites 20
30 répétitions alterné gauche et droite
durant à 5 séries pour un travail
optimal ne balancez pas le bras et pour
protéger vos genoux adoptez une bonne
position au niveau des
pieds